vous savez ce que j'adore quand je fis
spider man
absolument tout peter je peux entrer
non qu'est ce tu peux pas pour l'amour
du ciel laisse moi entrer
qu'est ce que tu as sur le visage tu es
couvert de crasse
oui oui un peu vu que j'ai ramené la
jeune et on n'a pas de cheminée
non
tous les matins en me réveillant j'y
pense même si je sauve de nombreuses
vies
même s'ils sont nombreux à me voir comme
un héros
quelqu'un d'encore plus puissant que moi
pour être tout changer
nous avons des projets pour toi peter
parker
l ampoule
ce n'est pas de taille pita
j'ai fait un choix
c'est mon destin
la chasse à l'araignée est ouverte
un coup de main
faut que j'y aille j avec toi tu es trop
dangereux désolé je t'aime de passeport
[__]